We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Indusible. I'm Roman Mars. If I was a flower growing wild and free, all I'd want is you to be my sweet honey bee. And if I was a tree growing tall and green, all I'd want is you to shade me and be my
我们获得了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学为所有人促进生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu。这是“不可思议的99%”。我是罗曼·马斯。如果我是一朵野蛮生长、自由自在的花，我所希望的全部就是你能成为我的甜美小蜜蜂。如果我是一棵高大翠绿的树，我所希望的全部就是你能为我遮荫并成为我的
leaves. So the teenage girl named Juno is walking down the street with a half-empty one-gallon jug of sunny, de-citrus beverage in one hand. She passes a tree and everything becomes animated. It's kind of a low-fi, unpolished Xerox copy animation inspired by punk rock music flyers. How long did you have that main title music from Juno stuck in your head? It's still there, isn't it? Yeah, I think so. punk rock music flyers. And if I was a tree growing tall and green, All I'd want is you to shade me and be my lead. The title sequence immediately establishes
树叶。因此，这个名叫朱诺的十几岁女孩正沿着街道走着，手里拿着一个装有一半半加仑阳光柑橘饮料的罐子。她路过一棵树，一切都变得生动起来。这是一种低保真、未加修饰的静电复印风格动画，灵感来自朋克摇滚音乐传单。你把《朱诺》的主题音乐在脑子里盘旋了多久？它依然在那里，对吧？是的，我想是的。朋克摇滚音乐传单。如果我是一棵高大翠绿的树，我所希望的全部就是你能为我遮荫并成为我的树叶。片头立即确立了
Juno's quirky world view. You can't even try to sequence the music, so you must live with these songs for months at a time, right? Yes. As a title designer, it's very important that the music that you use in a sequence is something that you love, that you really enjoy working with because it can be rough otherwise.
朱诺古怪的世界观。你甚至不能强行给音乐编排顺序，所以你必须连续几个月忍受这些歌曲，对吗？是的。作为一名片名字幕设计师，你所使用的音乐必须是你所热爱、真正享受与之合作的音乐，这一点非常重要，否则过程会很艰难。
My name is Garrett Smith and I am a film title designer. Garrett and his partner, Jenny Lee, did the titles for Juno and Up in the Air, among others. My name is Ian Albenson and I am the founder and editor-in-chief of Art of the Title, a website that curates title design. Ian's title is awesome. It's a completely different set of people that do the work.
我叫加勒特··史密斯，是一名电影片名字幕设计师。加勒特和他的搭档珍妮·李曾为《朱诺》和《在云端》等电影设计过片名。我叫伊恩·阿尔宾森，是“片名艺术”（Art of the Title）网站的创始人兼主编，该网站专门策展片名字幕设计。伊恩的片名太棒了。做这项工作的是一群完全不同的人。
That do title sequences. People don't always realize that. And I don't always seem to be always surprised that, oh, someone actually thought about this and someone actually gets paid to design and to work on something so separate from the film, yet so connected to the film. Fundamentally, a title sequence is a presentation
也就是制作片名字幕的人。人们并不总是意识到这一点。而且我似乎总是惊讶于，“哦，原来真的有人考虑过这个，而且真的有人付钱去设计和制作一些与电影如此独立，却又与电影紧密相连的东西。”从根本上讲，片名字幕就是向观众呈现
of a legal document to the audience. It's a list of names of the crew and actors and everything who are associated with a film. And then there's the more interesting and artistic reason for the title sequence. Which is establishing tone and perhaps a storyline. But there are rules. What are you doing a studio film? The designer or the company will get a document that's maybe 10 to 15 pages long. If you just wrote out the text for the title sequence, it could fit easily on a single page.
一份法律文件。它是与电影相关的工作人员、演员及其他所有人的名单。然后是片名字幕更具趣味性和艺术性的原因。那就是确立基调，或许还有故事情节。但这里有规则。当你制作一部制片厂电影时，设计师或公司会拿到一份大约10到15页的文件。如果你只是把片名字幕的文字写出来，它很容易就能塞进单页纸里。
Of course, it's this 15 page document. And beside each title, there's several paragraphs of text about how each title needs to be treated. Like maybe in some sequences, the lead to actors require their names to be bigger than the other titles. And they'll actually list in the document the exact percentage size that it needs to be bigger than the other titles in the sequence. So it's very specific and as a designer it gets very frustrating and challenging to deal with this because it feels very limiting to need to have every single title in the sequence be exactly the same size. When it comes to innovation and influence in title design, there are two words you need to know.
当然，这是那份15页的文件。在每个片名旁边，都有几段关于每个片名该如何处理的文字。比如在某些片段中，主演的名字需要比其他片名更大。他们甚至会在文件中列出比片中其他片名需要大多少的精确百分比尺寸。所以它是非常具体的，作为一名设计师，处理这些会变得非常令人沮丧和具有挑战性，因为要求片中的每一个片名大小完全一致，会让人感到极大的限制。当谈到片名字幕设计的创新与影响时，有两个名字是你必须了解的。
Saul Bath. He was a major benchmark in terms of realizing that you could have good design in a title sequence. When Saul Bath came along, he was a designer that started to work on more promotion for films and then started to bring his illustration and design style to films. He worked with Hitchcock on a number of pieces. If the title sequences of Saul Bastard immediately springed mine to yourself a favor and Google an enemy of murder,
索尔·巴斯。在认识到片名字幕也可以拥有优秀的设计方面，他是一个重要的里程碑。索尔·巴斯出现时，他是一位开始为电影制作更多宣传品，然后开始将自己的插画和设计风格带入电影的设计师。他曾与希区柯克合作过多个作品。如果你脑海中立刻浮现出索尔·巴斯的片名字幕，帮自己一个忙，去谷歌搜索一下《死吻》、
a man with a golden arm or psycho or a vertigo, so good. What I love about some of his earlier title sequences is if you look at them, they're basically animated film posters. But a lot of that Saul Bastyle faded away in the 80s. You know, the 80s and the 90s, you started to get the branding idea with films. And so a lot of title sequences weren't so much title sequences, but were just sort of the logo of the film.
《金臂人》、《惊魂记》或《迷魂记》，太棒了。我喜欢他早期片名字幕的地方在于，如果你仔细看，它们基本上就是动画电影海报。但索尔·巴斯的许多风格在20世纪80年代逐渐消失了。你知道，在80年代和90年代，你开始接触到电影的品牌概念。因此，许多片名字幕与其说是片名字幕，不如说是电影的标志。
And so you're creating the brand for the film. So you have back to the future where it's a very iconic logo design. And you have a lot of that in late 80s and early 90s. You didn't see as many complete opening sequences or title sequences be them standalone or sort of integrated with the film. Which is not done very much these days. I don't know if you've noticed that, but there are not a lot of films where there's just a big logo that you see on the poster, you know? But then we hit the second major benchmark, the movie 7. It's titles were created by Kyle Cooper. He sort of reintroduced the idea that the title sequence could be its own thing,
所以你是在为电影创造品牌。比如《回到未来》，它有一个非常标志性的标志设计。80年代末和90年代初有很多这样的设计。你看不到那么多完整的片头或者独立的、或是与电影融为一体的片名字幕。如今这种做法已经不多见了。我不知道你有没有注意到，但有很多电影里，你看不到那种你在海报上看到的巨大标志，你知道吗？但随后我们迎来了第二个重大里程碑，电影《七宗罪》。它的片名由凯尔·库珀创作。他某种程度上重新引入了这样的理念：片名字幕可以自成一体，
which is what bastard decades earlier. The title sequence of Seven works as both a standalone vignette and as a vital introduction to the grimey and obsessive feel of the movie. The serial killer in Seven doesn't appear until two thirds of the way into the film, but you really get to know the killer right here in the first two minutes. Kyle Cooper took us inside his head. The most memorable title sequences are really ones where, you know, there's a great movie after it. If Seven was put in front of some, you know, terrible movie that no one saw, it wouldn't have moved on to influence a generation of title designers after it.
正如巴斯几十年前所做的那样。《七宗罪》的片名字幕既可以作为一个独立的短片，也可以作为对这部电影阴暗、执着氛围的至关重要的介绍。《七宗罪》中的连环杀手直到电影进行了三分之二才出现，但你确实在前两分钟里就真正了解了这个杀手。凯尔·库珀把我们带进了他的脑海。最令人难忘的片名字幕往往是那些后面紧跟着一部伟大电影的作品。如果《七宗罪》被放在某个没人看过的烂片前面，它就不会去影响后来的一代片名字幕设计师了。
One of Ian Elvinson's favorite title sequences is another Kyle Cooper creation, the island of Dr. Moro. It was the one that kicked Ian in the head and made him start noticing titles in the first place. But if you were smart, you probably didn't see the island of Dr. Marrow, and you don't know how cool the title sequence is. But every human on Earth over the age of 20 knows the name of Garrett Smith's favorite title sequence. The TV title sequence for Cheers.
伊恩·阿尔宾森最喜欢的片名字幕之一是凯尔·库珀的另一部作品《人魔岛》。正是这部作品给伊恩当头棒喝，让他开始注意到片名字幕。但如果你足够聪明，你可能没看过去《人魔岛》，也不知道它的片名字幕有多酷。不过，地球上所有20岁以上的人都知道加勒特··史密斯最喜欢的片名字幕的名字。电视剧《干杯》的片名字幕。
I can watch that endlessly. I remember liking it before I was a designer. I had anything to do with design. So I was trying to put my finger on why I like it. And of course, a great theme song on that title sequence makes a big difference. But it also just has lovely typography, very simple, lovely typography, and the editing of the sequence is fantastic. It just captures the entire tone of the television show in 30 seconds to a minute. Cheers is a montage of historical drawings and photographs of people enjoying themselves
我可以一遍又一遍地看。我记得在自己成为设计师、还没接触设计之前就很喜欢它。所以我一直在琢磨为什么我喜欢它。当然，片名字幕中有一首极棒的主题曲会带来很大的不同。但它也拥有迷人的排版，非常简单、迷人的排版，而且这个片段的剪辑简直绝了。它在30秒到一分钟内就捕捉到了这部电视剧的整体基调。《干杯》是一组历史绘画和人们在酒吧里
in bars. And what they do underneath each of the title cards for the actors is they actually find a historical image that does sort of suggest that character in the television series. The reason I enjoy it is warmth and friendship, and that really comes across, I think, in that title sequence. There are a lot of fans of film title design out there. I was trying to figure out why that is, and I feel like film title design more than other sorts of design has a bit of a longevity, because it is committed to film. I guess a lot of design is commercial or prince, and it kind of is designed to exist for a week or two weeks, and then just to vanish from the face of the planet.
尽情享受的照片的蒙太奇。他们在演员的每个片名卡下方所做的，实际上是寻找一张确实能在某种程度上暗示电视剧中那个角色的历史图片。我喜欢它的原因在于它的温暖和友谊，我认为这种感觉在那个片名字幕中完美地传达了出来。外面有很多电影片名字幕的粉丝。我一直在琢磨这是为什么，我觉得电影片名字幕比其他类型的设计更有生命力，因为它被印刻在了胶片上。我想很多设计都是商业的或印刷的，它注定只能存在一周或两周，然后就在地球上消失了。
Whereas film design, you really do have to think about, what is this going to look like in 25 years? You hope that the movie you're working on is going to be one of those movies that's going to be seen many years from now, you know? And it has to kind of hold up over time. 99% Invisible was produced this week by me, Roman Mars, with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity.
而电影设计，你真的不得不去思考：25年后它会是什么样子？你希望你参与的电影会成为那种多年后仍会被人观看的电影，你知道吗？而且它必须经得起时间的考验。《不可思议的99%》本周由我罗曼·马斯制作，并得到了用创意创造差异的 Lunar 的支持。
It's a project of KALW-91.7, local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. For videos and links to all the titles we talked about in this episode as well as a kick-ass montage of kick-ass titles edited together by Ian Albinson. Go to the website, it's 99%invisible.org. Who I want to do a little social media outreach before you go. If you could go like this show on Facebook, that would mean great deal to me, because there's this other project that's
这是旧金山当地公共广播电台 KALW-91.7、旧金山美国建筑师协会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。有关视频以及我们在本期节目中讨论的所有片名字幕的链接，还有由伊恩·阿尔宾森剪辑的精彩绝伦的片名蒙太奇，请访问网站 99percentinvisible.org。在你离开之前，我想做一点社交媒体宣传。如果你能在 Facebook 上为这个节目点个赞，对我来说意义重大，因为还有另一个项目
actually really noble called the 99% and I just want to get more fans than that. So there's like a thousands and thousands and thousands of you like on average like 10, 12,000 of you listen to this weekly and I have almost 700 fans on Facebook so I think we can do better. Okay that's one. The other one is, if you would take the time to review this show and iTunes, you would not believe the impact it has. You're like a Nielsen family, but you get to choose yourself
其实非常崇高，叫做“99%”，我只是想获得比它更多的粉丝。所以你们大约有成千上万的人，平均每周有1万到1万2千人收听这个节目，而我在 Facebook 上只有将近700个粉丝，所以我觉得我们可以做得更好。好吧，这是一个。另一个是，如果你能花时间在 iTunes 上给这个节目写个评价，你绝对不会相信它带来的影响。你就像尼尔森调查家族一样，但当你对 iTunes 上的内容进行评价时，你可以自己做选择
when you review something on iTunes. It represents millions of people. It's crazy. The rankings, I go up instantly when I get one review in iTunes. So, if you could do that too, I hear five stars is a very popular option. That would mean so much. Alright, thank you, 9th percentile. We'll talk next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它代表了数百万人。这太疯狂了。当我收到一条 iTunes 评价时，我的排名会瞬间上升。所以，如果你也能那样做，我听说五星好评是一个非常受欢迎的选择。那将意味着太多。好吧，谢谢你们，第99百分位的人。我们下周聊。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。